e Herkese merhabalar e konuşmamı ufak
bir soruyla başlamak istiyorum kendi
hayatınızda başrolü siz misiniz ya da
kendi hayatınızda başvur muyuz Bu ve
bunun gibi soruları cevaplarken insanlar
genelde Evet tabii ki falan gibi
cevaplarda geliştirirler bu soruları
kendi kendimize sorduğumuzda böyle
Muhtemelen bu tarz cevaplar veriyor
olabiliriz ama bazı şeylerin üzerine
biraz fazla düşündüğümüz zaman kafa
yorduğu zaman o şeylerin cevapları biraz
daha Kafamızda netliğini kaybediyor ve
bulanıklaşıyor diye düşünüyorum bu günkü
konuşmamızda tamamen amacı bu aslında
Kafamızdaki bazı cevapları biraz daha
bulanıklaştırmak öncelikle şunu
belirtmek istiyorum ben bir psikoloji
öğrencisiyim ama burada anlatacaklarım
ın psikoloji bilim ile ya da herhangi
bir bilim dalıyla hiçbir alakası
olmayacak tamamen fikir aktarımı olarak
görüyorum ben burayı
abone ol
O sizin böyle görmenizi istedim ben
kimseden Ya sen nasıl psikoloji
öğrencisi bu anlattıklarımı psikoloji
alakası yok falan gibi bir tepki almak
istemem Yani onun için söylüyorum sadece
düşündüğüm şeyleri fark ettiğim şeyler
aktarmaya çalışacağım ve konuya giriş
yapmak gerekirse kendi hayatımızda
başrol olma bilinci diyorum ben aslında
bu neden önemli çünkü Aslında başta
biraz böyle bencilce gözükse de yani ben
başvurun kendi hayatımda kimseden bana
ne falan gibi gözükse de hiç öyle değil
tam tersi hatta kendi kendimizin
hayatımızda başrol olduğumuzu fark
ettiğimizde mi gerçekten fark
ettiğimizde diğer insanların da tek tek
kendi hayatlarında başrol olduklarının
farkına bölüyoruz ve çok güzel bir
farklılık Çünkü ben kendimize hem bütün
insanlara teknik saygı saygı da artıyor
ve bu saygısızlığın artması neticesinde
empati yeteneğinin de güçlendiğini
düşünüyorum ve birçok farklı şey de
olumlu etki yarattığını düşünüyorum bu
farkındalığın O yüzden önemli olduğunu
düşün
Selam bugün bununla alakalı konuşacağım
Evet peki bu başrol olma bilincini
etkileyen faktörler neler Tabii dünya
kadar faktör Vardır muhtemelen bunu
etkileyenleri burada konuşacağımız
konuşmadığımız fakat Bana en önemli
gelen üç tane et Kemal Usta'nın sorun
arasında sorulması gereken bunları bugün
paylaşacağım sizlerle birincisi
kendimizi gerçekten tanıyor muyuz
ikincisi gerçekten istediklerimiz ve
sevgilerimizi yapabiliyormuyuz bu
hayatta üçüncüsü de kendi kararlarımızı
verebiliyormuyuz et 1. madde kendimizi
gerçekten tanıyor muyuz Bu da yine Evet
tabii ki falan gibi bir cevapla
geliştirilebilecek sorulardan Ama yine
biraz düşündüğümüz zaman biraz daha
karmaşık da şu aslında konu kendimizi
tanımak derken gerçek nedenlerle
kendimizi tanımalıyız diye düşünüyorum
yani basit duygudurumu ifadeleri
kendimizi tanıdığımız göstermiyor Bana
kalırsa hemen şuraya gitmekten çok
hoşlanırım işte gümüşü saatinde Kendimi
hiç iyi hissetmiyorum berbat
hissediyorum kendimi falan
Evet bu da şeyler dışarıdadır rahat
gözlemlenebilen duygularımız Aslında
bizim ve bunlar bizi tanımlamıyor
bunların nedenleri ne biliyorsak o zaman
kendimizi bunu tanımaya tanımlamaya bir
adım daha yaklaşmış oluyoruz Bir de şey
diyeceğim çelişkilerden yararlanma
diyorum Ben buna bunu yapmamız lazım ve
gerçekçi olduğumuz lazım yani kendimize
bakıp Eskiden itibaren yıllardan
itibaren kendimize yaptığımız bazı
tanımlamalar vardır Biz bu tanımlamaları
çok sarılmış durumdayız Muhtemelen Kendi
yaptığımız davranışlara bakıp evet bu
davranış kendime yaptığım bu tanımlama
ile çelişiyor falan gibi bir açıklamayı
kendimize yapabiliyor olduğumuz lazım
Sen çok dürüst bulsam çok büyük dürüst
buluşalım diyorsan yıllardır kendi
kendime bana yalan söylüyorsun bir
yandan da çok basit bir örnek Baba
buradaki çelişki farkedip kendinize Yeni
tanımlamalar yapmamız lazım ya da hiç
tanımlama yapsak da olur evet kendini
tanımaktan sonra bir
o önemli konu kendi istediklerimizi ve
sevdiklerimizi Gerçekten
yapabiliyormuyuz bu da yine cevaplanması
ilk bakışta kolay bir soru çünkü hani
çok basit nedenselliğe dayanıyor bir şey
yaparız ve mutsuz olursak Eğer
istemediğimiz şey yapmışız demektir
mutlu olursak istediğimiz bir şey yapmış
demektir gibi bir mantık var bu şekilde
görünüyor Fakat burada ben birazdan
farkedilmeyen birşeye parmak basmak
istiyorum yine benim uydurduğum bir
kavram testi kaygısı dediğim bir şey
şöyle buradan 80 örnek vereceğim Tabii
bunun dünya kadar örneği olabilir ama
baktınız kısıtlı olduğu için ve Aslında
çok örnek vermeye de sevmiyorum çünkü
biraz daha Hani temeli atıp dinleyenlere
ve yeni şeyler farkedenler bırakmak daha
iyi oluyor Onların ve yani sizlerin bir
şeyleri fark etmesi daha hoş oluyor
bence o yüzden tek örnek veriyorum
Bunları akıllı farkettiğim popülerlik
örneği
Bu popülerliğe karşı tepki yani burada
insanların ikiye ayrıldığını düşünüyorum
Bir grup insanlar popüler olan şeye
yetişmek ve ondan geri kalmamak
arzusunda oluyorlar popüler olanı tercih
ettikleri zaman kendilerini daha
saygıdeğer prestijli hissediyorlar
ikinci gruptaki insanlarsa tam tersini
pozisyonda popüler olan şehir reddedip
kimsenin yapmadığı kimsenin dinlemediği
müzikleri dinlemek filan gibi şeyler
yapıp bunun farklı olmanın daha daha
Saygılar ve daha prestijli olduğunu
düşünüyorlar iki grubun da ortak noktası
Aslında Prestij hangisini Aslında demek
istedim Hani ikinci gruptaki insanlara
ele alırsak bir kimsenin dinlemediği
müzikleri dinleyen bir kişi Belki
herkesin dinlediği o popüler müziği
dinlediğinde alacağız daha yüksek olacak
olmasına rağmen bunu bulamıyor bunu fark
edemiyor Çünkü popüler olan kaçma çabası
içinde Evet geldik bugün
en son maddeye ve Son soru ya ya Kendi
kararlarımızı verebiliyormuyuz bu
hayatta Aslında bunun biraz daha
öneminden bahsedeceğim neden önemli
kendi karşılığını verebiliyor olmak
kendi kararlarını verebilir olmanın
özgürlük kavramıyla çok bitişik ve
birebir olduğunu düşünüyorum yani ne
kadar erken yaşta kendi kanalımızı
vermeye başlarsak o kadar fazla
özgürlüğümüze bireysel özgürlüğümüze
ipleri elinize almanızı o kadar hızlı
bir şekilde geçiş yapabiliyorsunuz aynı
zamanda kendi kararlarımızı verebiliyor
olmamızın daha da önemli bir yanı var
bence şöyle bir şey var bizim yerimize
karar alınırsa Eğer bizim yerimize
kararlar alındığında bu alan kişilere
Beynimiz olabilir sevgilimiz olabilir
eşiniz olabilir çevremizdeki herhangi
bir olabilir Çok yakın unuttuğumuz
Olabilir bizim yerimize Eğer kararları
alınıyorsa Bu kararlar sonucunda
yaşadığımız mutsuzluk lardan biz Ders
çıkartıyoruz Normalde insanlık olarak
insanlara
Bu yaşadığımız mutsuzluk lardan ders
çıkarmamız bu huzursuzluk lardan dersler
çıkarmamız ve gelişerek ilerlememiz
gerekiyor fakat birileri bizim adımıza
kararlar aldığında biz bunlardan ders
çıkartıyoruz Neden Çünkü yeterli
nedenselliğe sahip olduğumuza inanıyoruz
yani elimde zaten geçerli bir sebep var
Ben niye mutsuz oldum
ve bu kişi böyle karar verdiği için
kişinin yüzünden suçluya biliyoruz
suçluya bilmek ders çıkarmanın önündeki
en büyük engeldir diye düşünüyorum ve
bizim adımıza kararlar alındığında bu bu
şekilde işliyor Maalesef o yüzden kendi
kararlarımızı verebiliyor olmamız Hem
bireysel özgürlüğümüz için hem de
kişisel gelişmemiz için bence altın
değerinde bir şey ve sonuç olarak
özetleyecek olursam kendi hayatınızda
başrol olabilmemiz için bence en önemli
olan üç yeden bastım kendimizi
tanımalıyız Ve bunu yaparken gerçek
acımasız nedenlere ne bilmeliyiz ve
çelişkilerden de yararlanabiliriz
kendinize gözlemlediğimiz Biz ikinci
olarak kendi istediklerimizi ve
sevdiklerimizi gerçekten yapabiliyor
olmamız için Prestij kaygısı dediğim
şeyden olabildiğince uzak durmalıyız ve
onu çok bulursam alacağım diye
düşünüyorum ve üçüncü olarak da kendi
kararlarımızı verebilmenin öneminden
bahsettim sizlere bugün
ve bu kadardı dediğim gibi bu bilimsel
bir konuşma olmadığı için sadece bir
fikir paylaşımı olaraktan bunu gördüm
için sizlerden geri dönüşleri de
bekliyorum herhangi bir konuda
tartışabiliriz yani şuraya şöyle
söylemişsin ama ben böyle düşünüyorum
falan gibi ya da ya Çok haklısın ama
şöyle şöyle falan filan her geri dönüşü
bekliyorum ve herkese hepimize kendi
hayatınızda başrol olduğunuz unutmadınız
unuttuysak da hatırlayacağımız ömürler
diliyorum görüşmek